meanwhile on the hill it is you say
coochie in his 19th starting all-star
this year six and five record of 395
era in 109 in the third he has 117
strikeouts 12 of those strikeouts in his
last outing
check swing he goes one two three
top of the first for kikuchi including
his first strikeout of the day
jake odorizzi is the pitcher for your
houston astros today
this will mark his 205th start in his
career
i know it's important for him to not
only pitch every five days but to also
give the bullpen a break when he can
how about that a 3-2 fastball right down
the middle
mitch haninger expecting something else
correa at second tucker the runner at
first the stretch and the 3-2 offer and
it's down low and inside he bounces it
for ball
four but now the bases are loaded with
one out
straw on the ground towards short no
chance to turn a double play with straw
they get the force at second but the
astros take the lead
it's one to nothing as carlos correa
crosses the plate
and kikuchi gets him with a 95 mile an
hour fastball but the astros pick up an
unearned run time france leads off the
mariners second
gosh man
what is going on
france says he is okay that's the second
time
in a week he's been hit in the head
oda rizzi clearly did not mean to do
that kind of in a one-two count
see it bothers him he went over to
apologize and this just gets away from
him
off his shoulder that guard that he has
on there protect his face looks like he
gets a piece of that
[Music]
scary duvet grounded out his first time
up
here's a 2-1 and altuve lines it into
left-center field for a base hit
well that worked and altuve now he's
racing the second
the throw in by kelnick is offline
excellent base running by altuve
kelnick had to go far to his right and
it looked like he assumed
that altuve was just going to stop at
first base
didn't have quite the urgency that he
probably needed
and so altuve took advantage and it's
a hustle double for jose that's altuve's
14th double of the year
that'll be up to julie guriel to try and
drive in a two-out run here
yuli hits it hard to left field going
back long he watches it bounce off the
base of the wall
out two they will score guriel in the
second base
rbi number 60 on the year for euler in a
two-nothing astros lead
such a good job by yuli pulling the
hands in to get to that cutter
you can see kikuchi getting on the side
of it trying to get in on the hands but
yuli does such a good job of leading
with that knob and pulling the hands
through and when the barrel gets that
baseball it's easy to launch through it
julie just an rbi machine
tries to check man
he checks and it's not called a strike
because that clipped the corner
and now scott's on the top of the dugout
steps and he's
letting him hear it and now they
appeal and hunter willstead says that he
doesn't go
and now scott just got run what yep
wow that was quick under windows 10 our
crew chief
[Applause]
this has been a pretty emotional series
there's been a lot going on in this home
stand obviously
god not happy at all he probably knows
too that adam beck has been squeezing
you say he's missed a bunch of pitches
in the strike zone
in fact i know he knows it
you could tell that you say was
frustrated and even tom murphy on that
last pitch that wasn't called
so scott had enough
that quick hook very quick and he just
gave hunter the heave hole
here's the biz diaz batting
diaz in the left field that's going to
be down for a hit
around third comes mccormick he's going
to score great at bat by a led miss diaz
with an rbi
single the astros in front now three to
nothing that's just gonna
add to the frustration of kikuchi and
murphy
ball not hit hard but still a great job
of putting the ball in play
forcing fastball up and in off the label
of oledmos diaz just
passed his stretched out j.p crawford to
drive in a two-out rbi
julie guriel stands in against seattle's
usa kikuchi
the 0-1 and guerrielle hits it to center
deep
kelnick racing back on the warning track
looking up see you later
just to the right of the 401 foot marker
and straight away center field
yuli guriel with his first homer since
june 11th
and the astros have a four nothing lead
11th home run of the year for eule
he came into this game which is five
extra base hits over his last 37 games
all of them doubles
and he has an rbi double and a home run
this afternoon so far
as the astros score for a fourth
consecutive inning
and now it's altuve with a runner in
scoring position
hit hard past the diving shortstop
crawford being waved around his straw
here comes a throw by long junior safe
at home plate
mile straw speed gives the astros
another run it is five
nothing houston astros continuing to
build that picket fence on that base hit
by
jose altuve five straight innings of at
least
one run here's oled miss diaz he has an
rbi single
and that's lined in the left field
that's going to be down for a base hit
and one hop off the wall altuve trots
home
diaz racing for second he's in standing
up with an rbi double
six-nothing astros diaz with his second
rbi
of the day and his third rbi since
coming off the
injured list with multiple rbis he and
led miss diaz the cube in connection
today
have two rbi's each kellnick falls
that's going to be down for a hit
that's going to score a run julie guriel
with a routine fly ball to center
and kellneck fell down and the astros
now lead seven to nothing
how about that for an rbi things go on
the astros way
now correa shoots one into right center
field that's down for a hit all the way
to the wall
past jake bowers yulia on the move to
third he'll be waved around
he's gonna score eight nothing astros
with a four
run sixth inning
three straight games of eight runs for
the houston astros
taking advantage of mistakes not only on
the defense but also
in the zone correa aggressive early
taking 95
center cut hitting a rocket shot into
right center field
bottom six brings up kyle seeker
they get it sieger tags this out to
right field
he has got deep again
seeger has homer in
every game this series
his 21st this year
he tried to hit a few fly balls to left
field a few times and
i guess he said i'm gonna go back over
here and go to the right center gap now
but i know i can get it out
abraham toro climbs in one out a run in
and a man aboard
here's 1-1 otoro swung on high drive
right field
look at this baby fly away out of here
home run
abraham toro two days two homers as a
mariner this is a two-run
shot and we got an 8-3 ball game could
this be
yet another chapter of a mariner
comeback
they did it last night fell a little bit
short you're well aware of what happened
two nights ago
abraham turo making some friends here in
seattle
another 3-2 off the plate bases load and
walk
third walk from javier here comes dusty
cole third strike the slider on the
inside corner and a big reaction from
brian abreu
as murphy called out on strikes to end
the inning
here's kyle tucker
into left field hit pretty well back is
long looking up gone
kyle tucker with home run number 20 on
the air
astros now with 11 runs in the game
lead it 11-4
swing and a miss belak gets jared
kelnick
and that will end the game as kelnick
strikes out to finish this one off
plummer the astros scored 27 runs in
this three-game series and take
two out of three from a hot mariners
team